hey everyone its Mike mortal foes and I
just want to shoot this quick video to
discuss the volume profile and how to
use it with order flow analysis now this
is the bones from Monday and this
morning Tuesday March 12th and 13th of
2018 oh it's been a while since I've
done some videos I just got a lot of
stuff going on in my personal life at
the moment that were trying to get all
sorted out and I really was hoping to
have more videos done this year but you
know as luck and fate would have it I'm
a little bit behind the eight ball but
you know I'm starting to carve out the
extra time during the day and hopefully
get start getting more videos up here on
a regular basis but before I begin a
brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only and should not be
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a futures contract or making any type of
investment decision future train
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all are more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost not jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading only those were sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
before it's not necessarily indicative
of future results tools I use in this
presentation I'm just using the order
flows trader software which is the
volume footprint chart and it runs on
ninjatrader 7 and at ninja trader 8 so
let's let's take a look at the bones it
was very interesting so lately you know
the last couple of weeks there's been a
lot of interesting things happening in
the markets I've been a lot of
volatility and I just saw something
yesterday and watched it develop this
morning in the buns and you know I want
to shoot this quick video just to show
you how you can use the different tools
and in order flow together to hopefully
find better trades and improve your
trading so let's take a look okay so
yesterday in the buns we had this very
we had this P shape formation on the
volume profile it's it's the pro fits
the histogram there on the left side of
the chart and you can see it's just your
classic P shape which indicates
short-covering in the market and what
was interesting about this is basically
since about you know 6:30 7:00 in the
morning until until the close we were
just trading in this tight range from
the high up there at what is that 36
basically down to 24 and you know we're
just hanging hanging in there tight
range and then we closed for the day
then we reopen on
bottom end but when you see a shape like
this you know it's very tight very tight
range but a fairly compact Rangers
Monday in the buns you know not not a
whole lot to really move the market and
you ended up for the basically almost
over half the session just trading in
that very tight range to close out the
session now if you look on a daily chart
okay so this is the Bulls daily chart
and you know basically since last week
you know we've had this low down here I
was at 156 about 28 29 and we've been
rallying up so it's not surprised to see
some short covering this is today's bar
here the 13th this is yesterday's bar so
you know we shot up and we just sort of
hung around here now again if you're
using a normal candlestick chart or a
bar chart most people use candlesticks
nowadays because it's a little easier on
the eye to determine stuff but you know
you wouldn't eat you couldn't determine
that you had this piece shape forming
right here in the volume profile you
know that's why you know candlesticks
are you know that they're sort of a
rudimentary form of vertical analysis
and the terms of yeah you can see what
the high the low was where or the market
opened closed and you know did the
market closed higher than it opened but
beyond that there's not much else you
really can glean too much from just a
bare naked candlestick chart but if you
saw the volume profile what do you see
you see that P shape which indicates
short-covering
now it wasn't this between
short-covering and you know a market
bought to rally well realize you know we
just come up from you know basically
about 100 points you know 100 point
rally and from last week you know even
had the load down here on sixth but you
know what a rallying up rallying up so
all these people even he had people that
were you know short from here markets
sold off thinking okay yeah it's fine
but now what it's starting to come back
up it's trying to come back up towards
you know the high is the monthly highs
so you know all these people that was
short you know realize hey you know what
we're not selling offer we're on our way
back up so we just had a move up came
off a little bit okay you know they're
taking this opportunity to get out here
rather than you know breaking out to new
highs now why is this important well
under the day on Monday right so you
have this P shape which in
it's short-covering now when you have
short-covering you know you want to be
looking is it just short covering or is
there new initiating positions coming
into the market and you just don't see
anything on this day yesterday I mean
you just go through that you know you
can just see every time you'd rather you
get signs of price rejection you know in
the order flow even here you come off to
the lower end of this value area you've
got price rejection down here price
rejection up there so it's sort of
indicating that we're going sideways I
mean the other the other thing that
we're going sideways is you just sort of
see these alternating bars want to
control the bars you know there's almost
even you can see it right here but you
know as the big goes on you know we're
not really going anywhere you know with
the individual bars pointed controls so
then coming into today on the 13th again
you know what happens and we open up
here so we're on the lower end of the
value area and you know if you were to
take yesterday's value area right it's
basically you know 24 you know if you
were to draw a line out and you know
this is why it's important to understand
where yesterday's value area is you know
when you know open when you know where
the value area is yesterday especially
if you have a pea shape or a B shape
then you know it's going to give you a
little bit more information coming into
the next day now not every day you're
going to have a pea shape like this but
on the days you do watch for the next
day okay so it's just you know take you
know a brief eyeballing value area we'll
call that value area low obviously this
will be the value area high up here even
if you won't call it 36 but I call it 34
so this is your value area from
yesterday all right you can see how
we're just training inside that range
yesterday so coming into today and watch
what happens okay we break down rally
back into it break down rally back into
it break down get down
you know through it you know we come all
the way down here to 15 but then watch
what happens
you got a single print here indicating
price rejection so you got some signs
that price is being rejected below value
yesterday's value area low then there's
your rallying back up boom you get this
nice stack buying and balance up in here
you just make this card a little bit
bigger and that's a good sign you know
you're coming up you're coming up to
yesterday's high you've got a stack mine
and balance you've got a stack binding
balance as you're getting ready to break
through
yesterday's value area high as well so
you're in yesterday's value area you
just tested below it obviously it got
rejected you're trading back into it so
chances are if we're gonna start
breaking above it you know position
yourself here you could have got you
know if people were to buy that breakout
you got a couple quick ticks but watch
it again as you broke through you come
back in and then you see the buying
imbalances again you know this is a
great bar right here this for for 15 bar
to look to be getting long I mean you
should have been getting long you know
in this bar right here but by the time
you start seeing this other buying
imbalance 988 here 924 here you know
it's all systems go and then we we pop
up really quick over the next basically
next two or three minutes
you know from 3738 all the way up to you
know 48 that's a quick 10 ticks you do
get a little selling you have stacks on
a balance so you guys you rally up to
the high today at this point in the buns
and you get stacks selling imbalance
okay I like stacks element balances at
the high of the day it's a great short
opportunity and you know if you're
getting short here 42 43 you know what
are you trade you're gonna try it right
back into yesterday's value area I'm
back down to 33 it's another 10 ticks so
you got a nice move up here a nice move
back down in here no notice we're not
really you know the market at this point
is is you know it's just has it accepted
it yet no we're just sort of hanging
around hanging around hanging around and
then you know watch as you start trading
away from that value area you know
what's the potential well if we're
trying to move away from that value area
if the market is no longer accepting
that value area what's going to happen
it's going to find a new value area
alright and it's either going to be
above it or below it so you gotta look
for those
in the order flow and you can see it
here starting to move up you got the
higher point of controls one two three
right here you know before all the
pointed controls in the bars are inside
now you're starting to see the point of
controls outside obviously the bars are
trading above it
but again you know it's a nice
opportunity then here you got single
print single print indicating you know
there's there's price rejection down
here that we know what you know we're
rejecting yesterday's value area even
though you know starting to rally but
it's leaving these little tails here
saying hey you know what we're rejecting
that value area down in here the value
area from yesterday and then BOOM again
we rally all the way up to sixty so you
know that was interesting
that was to me that was very interesting
information that you could have just
gleaned from a simple order flow volume
footprint chart and using volume profile
again you know it's not every day you
get those pshape formations but when you
do you know pay attention to them watch
how the market reacts the next day you
know if there's ticks to be had in the
market every day so you know sometimes
it's it's more obvious than others but
yesterday Monday was with that P shaped
formation and a fairly tight range it it
gave a trader opportunities coming into
the next day to trade around so if you
want to learn more about order flow
subscribe to my youtube channel or visit
order flows comm and again you know if
you're more interested in order flow go
to my website you can find out a lot
more information about order flow so
thanks everyone bye-bye